[Applauso]
buonasera qualche tempo fa un ragazzino
oggi si parla molto di piccoli bambini
che innescano un processo cognitivo un
ragazzino mi chiede che il mestiere
facesse e io gli dissi che traducevo dei
libri e lui mi chiese se traducevo si
traducesse di nuovi o vecchi gli chiesi
io risposi tutte e due
e lui mi chiese ma quelli vecchi non
sono già stati tradotti
io dissi sì sono stati tradotti male
no no sono stati tradotti benissimo e
allora perché liri traduci e io che
dissi perché noi invecchiamo perché la
lingua cambia perché 38 30 anni o forse
anche meno una traduzione invecchia
perché noi non siamo più quelli di 25
anni fa allora il ragazzino tutt'altro
che stupido mi disse ma se una
traduzione di 25enne fa è già vecchia
figurati l'originale
allora dico è inutile questo tuo
mestiere riscrivi decisamente di
completamente di nuovo all'originale e
fai questo lavoro un'unica volta
questa la reazione dei ragazzi nella
tutt'altro che stupida in realtà quello
che noi facciamo ogni volta che noi
leggiamo un libro e ogni volta erano
rileggiamo un libro di molti anni fa
diciamo un originale noi lo riscriviamo
per cercare di capire perché di un unico
testo esistono molte possibili
traduzioni tutte valide tutte diverse
possiamo pensare all originale come un
territorio e alla traduzione come una
cartografia come una mappa come una
forma di modellazione pensiamo al a un
territorio un territorio fatto di picchi
di valli di
di un profilo con i laghi mari e il
territorio è l'originale il cartografo e
traduttore e qualcuno che ha visitato il
territorio che ci ha camminato che la
percorso e che cerca di riprodurlo ma
una traduzione non è un facsimile
dell'originale avo una volta si diceva
la traduzione è un tradimento non è un
tradimento
la traduzione è una forma di
modellazione una traduzione non deve
fare non deve tradurre ciò che il testo
originale è una carta non è torio una
traduzione è un modello che cerca di
produrre che studia il territorio per
produrre e riprodurre quello che il
territorio fa non quello che il
territorio è cioè nazione di un testo
sul proprio lettore
ora naturalmente il territorio è fatto
di parole e il cartografo traccia una
traduzione cioè una mappa fatta di
parole tra questi due spazi che si
guardano c'è tutto l'ambito della
traduzione
ora una traduzione valida bella antica
per noi inservibile potrebbe somigliare
una cosa del genere
una una mappa del genere non ci
servirebbe più oggi andare in autostrada
ma vediamo perfettamente di che cosa si
tratta
ecco una tradizione antica che potrebbe
certamente funzionare come un nuovo
territorio
ogni traduzione ogni mappa può diventare
il territorio di a sua volta un
territorio e produrre delle mappe
successive questo è qualcosa di molto
affascinante ed è una operazione mentale
che io consiglierei a tutti perché è
un'attività quella del traduttore e
quella del cartografo traduttore che ha
in sé intrinsecamente il senso
della propria data di scadenza una
traduzione in fondo è un modello che
fissa lo stato delle cose
il nostro stato delle cose e lo stato
delle cose della lingua di una comunità
di parlanti eri pensanti che ci parla
una lingua non si possiede è la lingua
prix portiera e noi ora vi faccio un
esempio
questo è un particolare di una stampa da
piranesi
come potete vedere si vede un pezzo di
arco e vediamo un pezzo di fiume è un
enorme quantità di piante
ora se questo fosse il nostro territorio
da tradurre il cartografo traduttore
funziona in un rapporto di vicinanza o
di distanza più ci avviciniamo più
zoomiamo sul nostro territorio più
zoomiamo sulla lingua straniera più ci
caliamo dentro più scene allontaniamo è
più in fondo tracciamo qualcosa che
tralascia molti particolari e somiglia
soprattutto a noi se io a zugo molto
finisco ad avere questo in cui io perdo
il disegno generale e si diffonda in
particolare ora noi siamo tutti figli di
google ormai è la nostra civiltà il
nostro tempo pensa in termini di zoom
ogni ritraduzione ultima di grandi
classici del passato interessante perché
va molto di più nel particolare quando
io mi sono trovata ritradurre pilota di
guerra di saint exupéry quello del
piccolo principe che in italia si
conosce solo per il piccolo principe in
realtà era uno scrittore che parlava di
guerra ma soprattutto è nella traduzione
precedenti bellissime sontuose di questo
testo erano stati tralasciati tutti i
termini tecnici che descrivevano il
quadro di bordo dell'aereo
perché per una sensibilità passata non
erano così importanti per da tradurre
non erano così importanti da trasferire
per trasferire nella nostra modellazione
ora vi farò un esempio interessante di
perché la lingua cambia e noi cambiamo e
del perché il traduttore usa delle
parole che non sono mattoncini inerti ma
le parole che compongono il la
modellazione di un territorio hanno una
massa e come direbbero i fisici una
mappa una massa curva lo spazio tempo
della nostra parete di modellazione vi
faccio un esempio elogio dei campi è un
titolo di un capitolo di un famoso del
romanzo distopico che io mi sono trovato
a tradurre terminus radioso di un grande
scrittore che si chiama voluti e se io
traduco la lettera e lo cede co elogio
dei campi a cosa pensate campi
sostanzialmente gran parte delle persone
oggi pensano qualcosa del genere
elogio di questo dei campi
questo è una fotografia
i campi intorno a roma ed è quindi un
immagine bucolica
ora il titolo del capitolo distopico
voleva dire ben altro voleva dire elogio
di qualcosa del genere cioè il francese
liscio e lecco
sono due cose molto diverse i campi di
grano sono gli show sono the rise and i
campi di concentramento di detenzione di
lavoro sono le co ora noi in italiano
che monica parola per tradurre queste
due cose molto molto diverse e allora io
come traduttore sono responsabile
dell'azione dell'ondulazione che la
parola che uso crea nella superficie
della mia immaginaria nappa quindi io
sono stata costretta aggiungere rispetto
all'originale qualcosa in più elogio dei
campi di lavoro normalmente non si tesse
l'elogio di un campo di lavoro di un
campo di concentramento
se non all'interno di una grandiosa
metafora ironica tragicamente ironica
perché dentro i campi di lavoro di
concentramento forse esista meglio che
all'esterno
pensate però tra 20 o 25 anni quando
probabilmente chi nasce oggi non avrà
più un esperienza nei campi di grano o i
fiori ma avrà soprattutto un
associazione mentale un'esperienza di
qualcosa del genere
ovverosia l'elogio dei campi avremo
un'esperienza generale
fate di campi di rifugiati o di campi di
concentramento ora pensate
la nostra traduzione tra vent'anni sarà
datata e quella nostra parolina che
abbiamo inserito in più elogio dei campi
di lavoro non sarà più necessarie ci
vorrà qualche ora per ora fate che sono
andate avanti questa è un'immagine per
parlare della traduzione di quello che
noi facciamo a cui tengo molto e animali
nel 1888 inserita in una azione
divulgativa su che cosa fosse il nastro
l'astronomia per tutti e come potete
vedere c'è un piccolo astronomo che
capisce che oltre la nostra volta
celeste cioè oltre il nostro sistema
solare c'è altro
il piccolo astronomo capisce che al di
fuori ci sono altri mondi altri sistemi
ebbene il traduttore e come il piccolo
astronomo sa che dopo oltre il nostro
sistema linguistico ce ne sono altri ce
ne sono altri si possono dire altre cose
nello spazio tra il nostro sistema e un
altro tra la lingua del territorio e
quello della mappa esiste un margine di
manovra in cui la traduzione opera mi
piace a questo punto citare una poesia
di una poi molto giovane e contemporanee
che si chiama giulia martini che ha
scritto una bellissima poesia e qui dice
io tour i migliori made to vai verso
quello che credi e io verso quello che
rimane in fondo il traduttore fa questo
è qualcuno che media tra quello verso
cui andiamo e decidiamo di andare
e quello che rimane in questo spazio
critico e dialettico sta tutta la
traduzione e per concludere vorrei
pensare al fatto che come work in
progress ogni traduzione traccia il
ritratto della nostra epoca di quello
che siamo noi adesso in questo momento e
non solamente questo ma il traduttore in
fondo traccia sempre soltanto il
ritratto di se stesso questa è una
bellissima immagine con cui vorrei
concludere questo breve flash è un
bellissimo quadro fiammingo in cui
quello che io voglio dire e cioè che la
mappa di un misterioso territorio
precedente
in fondo traccia il ritratto di chi la
disegna penso che sia
secondo set
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]